at
ner sponsor Hall
um so if you've not been at Nur so far
welcome uh for your virtual experience
of this event this is the vendor Hall so
people here trying to present themselves
and hire various people
um
so here we have some places a lot of
people are and some places there are no
people at
all and then the cool companies they'll
have actual researchers here and then
the uh non cool companies they will just
have some marketing people here they
Disney in view I don't know these are
these are people that split off from
something but I'm not sure exactly where
from
[Music]
so
together these are kind of Zurich
based there's de Mund
connection is very poor I'm sorry okay
this is conference
Wi-Fi that's what you
get here's P torch
lightning where Q star I don't know I
can ask who do I ask the open AI folks
probably there's Google deep mindes
they're probably hit HP on
Gemini uh let's see if we can find
someone who knows
anything about
Gemini there's no one here that I know
of the
researchers there
Citadel there is
a lot of financial stuff here you'll
never see research out of these people
but when you go up to them they'll
essentially
pay extremely well and
uh pay extremely well if you come work
for us so you go there you don't really
I'm not sure what they exactly
do but let's on FR WiFi
was but I'll try I'll try to get you
some content um for now we'll do this
the vendors are still going to be here
tomorrow
so I hope bring you something
then yeah see look this is financial
company this is I no clue but I would
guess a financial company then there is
G research which is a financial compan
tons tons and tons of quantitative
trading
companies Yanik is
broke yeah that's true broken
broken or there's meta let's see if we
can spot Yan laa wild Yan laa flying
around probably not I hear he's only
coming tomorrow
maybe oh Apple didn't see apple
yet what's that Co here I'll be there
and I'll Rec coh here is here
ha
I spot
a one of them at
least see who's at
[Music]
Microsoft
yeah we'll see if spot open a open a I
don't I have not seen a stand by them
they don't seem to be
here is quite big
[Music]
here IBM's right
there
[Music]
mym seems to be hit
looks like they here which is
cool let's go over
there very laggy I'm sorry I'm
sorry I
know
there
[Music]
scale give you the ability to
like the
track
yeah we're doing something private at in
at a machine learning conference yeah
that's it that's
it
uh vast is here vast is pretty
[Music]
cool some cool stuff
over oh no they're not actually the the
vast
that I know they're different
vast I mean vast AI I
[Music]
think
cerebras very cool very big
chips biggest chips on the
market we have the biggest chips we have
the best
chips
hi
[Music]
what's the goal of the booths it's
always
recruitment it's I mean for I guess for
the bigger companies it's a big bit of
marketing and just getting their name
here but it's mostly recruiting
uh
when you want your power drill to be
powered by an
[Music]
llm the BOS way you have to prompt it to
do the correct
drilling asra
zenica no
comments we have Bosch AI box nice I
actually have the new pair see trading
again so much trading here like all
these trading companies they they just
hire here I have a new weights and
biases socks and I so long didn't get
that this was see it's a wand and a b
okay wait you can't see it's not in
Focus yep see it's a wand and a b so uh
it's called One
DB and and
yeah hi I saw Live on YouTube how's it
going yeah good good very nice to meet
you I love your YouTube video thank you
thank you what's your name oh I'm oh
sorry am I interrupting not well not at
all all good the the chat says it's so
laggy that you can't see anything anyway
so intern here
is yeah I really
[Music]
like
where were we not there we didn't go
there yet let's
[Music]
see
well they are
smart they have
popcorn all right we're back we're back
there's
perplexity here's Comet now I have to be
biased because I'm one to be sponsored
so that's that
T wanted less ARS than this
stream
[Music]
nice
noic purpose of their AI as
what they make drilling machines for
God's sake
has anyone tried to head hunt you yet
yeah there there people saying they saw
me live on YouTube which was you know
cannot be more than 15 minutes ago
finding me here so all right which is
fun it's it's cool to meet
people uh well I don't think we have
been over there
yet let's
see
qualcom yeah I guess cuz my low power
chip needs an
llm look the financial companies they
have the the biggest
booths they have so much money if you
want to make
money I guess that's where you want to
go but you'll never see daylight
again I guess half of us don't see
daylight anyway but
alignment for the drill yeah
yeah more trading more
trading
Finance can AI fix the WiFi
I'm working on conference Wii well you
we could go to the right of that we just
put more compute in they didn't think
about what that mix
was and what the actual models that
people are running P
[Music]
actually look how much how many people
are at Google
deep
[Music]
oh this is about their materials
research know
the
goua let's see let's see lab they still
exist I can't believe it I cannot
believe
it what do they still
do they're a meme of the past look how
big their Booth is it's
[Music]
crazy
I kind of want to ask them but
uh it's a bit mean
no one MLB is the more profit I guess
they're more
profitable but they got to suffer since
all of pie torch
appeared look there's weights and biases
right at the entrance that's where you
want to be over there all the people
come in and here's the first move that's
like it's pretty optimal
placement all right people that was it
um I'm going to leave it at that because
uh yeah Wi-Fi situation is not good I
can try to record some stuff and just
put it out and you just pretend it's a
live stream okay we won't have chat uh
which I'm going to miss or maybe I can
try to get like some unlimited data plan
but I don't think they exist for such a
short time
um yeah so thanks for joining here and
I'll I'll try to bring more content as
the week progresses for all the people
who aren't who aren't here so see you
around
bye-bye